Ghostbusters is directed by Paul Feig
and stars Melissa McCarthy Kristen Wiig
Leslie Jones and Kate McKinnon has four
unlikely heroes that band together to
fight against an uprising of paranormal
activity in New York City man that
sounds like a movie I saw once that came
out in 1984 but I just can't put my
finger on it
in all honesty the own regards to the
Ghostbusters movies I like the first one
quite a bit I didn't see it as a kid
though I don't have nostalgia for
Ghostbusters I saw it for the first time
as an adult and I thought it was really
good a lot of fun good comic
performances impressive visuals for 1984
Ghostbusters 2 is a different story I
didn't really like that film I thought
that it was trying too hard I thought
that it wasn't very funny and that it
was kind of a recreation of the original
with certain elements just twisted
around slightly so when I saw the
trailers for this Ghostbusters there
wasn't any part of me that was thinking
oh this is ruining my childhood I hate
this I am never gonna watch this ever
this movie looks terrible women what the
I was just thinking that doesn't
look very funny that's unfortunate
because I like Paul Feig movies I've
actually like bridesmaids spy and the
heat you can see a couple blu-rays right
back there that I own I think he's a
very talented director and that he's
made some very funny movies so I went
into this movie with an open mind
because I think any film really deserves
a chance you shouldn't judge a book by
its cover or in this case a movie you
should give it a chance and see how it
is and that's what I did when it comes
to a reboot I look at it in a very
specific way because most reboots are
made for money let's face it we live in
a period where everything is remade
rebooted whether it's a TV show being
brought back or a movie being remade and
rebooted and remade again it's going to
happen a lot
and now Ghostbusters receives that
treatment because this is absolutely a
reboot it doesn't even acknowledge
events of the last two movies there were
never ghosts in New York City nobody
knows what that is and Bill Murray's
Ghostbusters team has vaporized into
thin air and no one knows what the
Ghostbusters are this is a brand new
movie with a brand new continuity and
the way I look at reboots is this does
it improve upon the original at all does
it add anything good to the franchise is
there a reason for this reboot to exist
beyond earning a lot of money
on a well-established name or brand
that's how I view reboots because most
of the time they're nowhere near as good
as the originals there are a handful
that are better like Ocean's eleven or
John Carpenter's The Thing and with this
new Ghostbusters there are only a
handful of things that I could find that
are actually better or improved upon
from the 1984 film one of them being
Chris Hemsworth has the receptionist
he had more screen time than the
original Ghostbusters receptionist he
was funnier
he had more things to do he actually
added something to the movie unlike the
original receptionist character and due
to advancements in technology that have
happened over the past 30 years or so
the action sequences have improved as
well so technically this film is an
improvement over the original in regards
to how it's constructed from sound
design and visuals does that really
matter though when your film is 30 years
older and those things are just going to
happen naturally as technology
progresses there are very few
improvements in this film when compared
to the original 1984 film and that's sad
because I am a fan of Paul Figgs movies
and I wanted this movie to be a lot
better than it is that being said this
film doesn't even come close to
deserving the amount of hate that it's
gotten it is not a Dragonball Evolution
it's not a Last Airbender it's just not
that great unfortunately and it's
nowhere near as good as that first
Ghostbusters film but I do think it's
better than Ghostbusters 2 and much of
that is due to the excellent chemistry
present between these four girls Melissa
McCarthy Kristen Wiig these two worked
marvelously together and I think Kristen
Wiig is really funny she's a really good
improvisational comedian as is Melissa
McCarthy I've liked her in a lot of
movies in the past but I've also not
liked her in some like say Tami
but at movies like spy or the heat or
bridesmaid she's really blown me away
when it comes to comedy I like Leslie
Jones a lot in top five these girls work
really well together and Kate McKinnon
is off and on for me she played sort of
a crazy person and I could tell that she
is really funny but her character it was
her character not necessarily her as an
actress but her character just didn't
quite always work for me but those four
as a team did have really good chemistry
with one another and notice that I've
been saying that I think all of these
actresses are really funny
because I do think all of these
actresses are really funny just not that
much in this movie some of these
actresses have split my sides with
laughter in previous movies and here
they just didn't bring it a lot of it
was the script it seemed like it was
trying too much to recreate certain
elements of the original as well as
bringing back some very very
unfortunately unnecessary cameos in
roles that were almost disrespectful to
the original in particular one person
who plays a scientist in this film and I
was just like not only is this not funny
but this isn't really respecting the
original really poor choices were made
with those cameos that just did not work
for this movie this movie's a bit of a
mixed bag for me because with all of the
whole like you're a misogynist if you
hate this movie thing it's tough to
really go about reviewing this movie
without being labeled something as
simple fact of the matter is I like all
these actresses I just didn't really
like this movie it wasn't very funny so
it's tough to traverse this next thing I
want to talk about but I'm going to
every male character in this movie is
either a idiot
a coward or an asshole and it's pretty
unprecedented I actually couldn't think
of one male character there wasn't one
of those three things also the final
resolution of this movie involves
another hitted men I don't want to spoil
it for you and I won't spoil it for you
but I was just kind of like wow guys to
put this all in a nutshell the cameos
didn't really need to be there the four
leads are funny and I would like to see
them in a funnier movie Hemsworth had
some really funny parts there are funny
scenes there are moments where I laughed
but overall it suffers when you compare
it to the original which it's trying to
erase and when you take reboots as a
whole as a thing there really is no
point to reboot a film if you can't
improve upon it because if you're not
improving upon it then what are you
doing hoping for some Bank I'm gonna
give Ghostbusters a see doesn't quite
deserve that hate that it got but it's
also not a good enough film to be like
yeah see it was actually great because
this is just kind of okay also be sure
to check out my reviews for the Bourne
Identity and the Bourne Supremacy that
I've already posted because I'm doing
on going really cool skit involving
Jason Bourne it's like a to be continued
thing and I'm having a ton of fun doing
it guys if you do see ghostbusters I am
curious to know what you thought of the
movie thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes